[Music]
hello and thank you for being here today
I sincerely appreciate it my name is
James Malone I'm a product manager with
Google cloud and today I'm going to be
joined by Zulily in just a little bit
and I want to talk through the topic of
digging and filling data Lakes
specifically I want to talk about how
you think about data lakes why people
create data lakes the value they can
provide and what they mean in terms of
architecture on Google cloud platform
so roughly we're going to frame what our
data lakes what do we mean data lakes
could mean a lot of things so I want to
fill in specifically kind of what we're
thinking about what we're talking about
going to talk about if you wanted to go
build a data Lake on GCP what does that
actually look like and then Zulily is
going to come on stage and walk through
their data platform which will give you
an indication of how somebody is built
to data Lake in Google cloud platform in
a real life scenario
so first what our data lakes and why do
they matter and it's a common phrase so
if you're familiar with data lakes I
apologize but I do want a level set just
so we form a common understanding of
what we mean by data Lakes so first and
foremost data lakes are a collection of
raw data they could be unstructured data
they could be structured data they could
be semi structured data it's really just
a collection of data that you've put in
a single store for a variety of purposes
so data Lake is a good term you could
look at as a giant container of data
it's essentially a collection of data
that you're going to use for some
purpose and it is in some format data
lakes typically have a few key features
first people often put a lot of raw or
unprocessed or pre-process data in a
data Lake so it's very common for people
to take all of their data in is a first
step just land it in a data lake until
they know what they want to do with it
second is very common for data lakes to
have a mix of structures so you may have
a data Lake that has a lot of
unstructured data but it was also
sprinkled with semi structured or
structured data after it's been
processed or in the middle of being
processed data lakes third are not tied
to processing so data lakes are kind of
the hallmark of the separation of
storage and compute so
you store data in a data Lake it's not
tied to any specific processing
technology and most commonly you'll see
that there's actually multiple
processing technologies that are used
against one data Lake itself that leads
to de Lakes being multi-purpose instead
of having one specialty function being
really good at one thing data lakes are
kind of a jack-of-all-trades in terms of
a data store they might not be the best
in one particular function but they
serve a lot of functions very well why
build a data Lake
well first scalability data lakes are
usually very scaleable so instead of
worrying about things like how much
capacity do I need or how many disks do
I have to buy instead you just think of
a data Lake is almost an infinite store
second there's less upfront work
required a key hallmark of data lakes is
that you can just put data in without
thinking too much about it you're not
having to pre-process the data or pre
apply schemas to data not having to
follow any particular formatting rules
data Lake really in an ideal sense
should just be as simple as putting the
data in a store and you're done you can
use a variety of tools with the data
Lake so a good data Lake will have api's
built on top of it it will have
third-party integrations that you can
use with it a data Lake should be
connected a data Lake off by itself or
usable only by a specific set of tools
that's not a great data Lake that's just
a really isolated data silo with maybe
more data in it or a variety of data
because it is well connected sort of
infinitely scalable it should really be
usable in a variety of circumstances
that means organizational circumstances
it means in terms of applications you
might use the data for analytics you
might use the data for ml you might use
the data just for archive and disaster
recovery and retention all of that is
done in a data Lake with cost in mind so
a real big reason that a lot of people
are interested in data lakes and build
data lakes is cost often when you reason
about what data to keep or not keep
you're trying to think about well how
much does the data cost is it worth the
data sitting around maybe I'm use it
maybe I won't data Lake theoretically
should remove as many of those cost
concerns
as possible so data lake sound great and
a lot of people talk about data lakes
and there's a lot of interest in data
lakes but there's a very fair question
of if data lakes are so great why isn't
everybody building them or why doesn't
everybody already have a data Lake well
I would postulate there's a few reasons
for that one of the biggest reasons I
would attribute to Conway's law simply
put your organizational structure will
often define how you organize in some
cases applications but I'm going to
apply it to data so essentially your
organization chart influences how you
think and break apart data so in this
very simple example you have a set let's
say these are different departments
inside of an organization they're going
to have their different applications
they're going to have their different
technologies they're going to have their
different needs all very legitimate all
very valid that's their view of the
world
unfortunately that siloed view of the
world is driving their technology
choices it's driving what data storage
technology they're thinking about what
processing tools they're using how they
think about structured or unstructured
data so without really thinking about it
the organizational chart is actually
almost clearly mapping to the technology
choices that they're going to make that
makes data integration really messy so
now you have all of these technologies
you have some data that's unstructured
you have some data that's structured and
it usually creates a really big plumbing
mess that you then need yet another
group to go and fix so you have three
different databases two data warehouses
raw data just sitting everywhere and now
you need a massive effort to go and try
and tie all of this together now I think
it's fair to say most people don't wake
up in the morning and think I'm gonna go
create just a giant data mess for myself
because that sounds like fun
instead it's their organizational chart
that's usually driving a lot of
decisions behind the scenes and they
just end up in a mess data is also as a
result of kind of being organizationally
driven it's not seen as an asset it's
usually seen as a cost in a lot of
aspects so you're thinking about okay
what technology do I need to store this
data
and then data becomes a cost center and
people are buying technology to store
the data but the end of the day you're
you're really just trying to think about
how can I lower my costs so how do i
optimize cost versus data being kept and
instead of actually deriving value from
your data you're just sitting there
trying to do a counting on your data and
I think it's fair to say that most
people don't find a lot of value out of
doing a counting on their data unless
they're dealing with financial data and
that's their goal it also means that any
duplication is highly inefficient so if
you have two groups that are storing
data when everything is a cost any
duplication inside of two technologies
that groups may not even know exists
outside of that particular group is
extremely inefficient it also makes
management a complete headache so you
have all of these different is a tional
groups they have all of the different
applications that are not only storing
but using data they have all of these
different retention policies they may
want to apply to data they have
different security requirements
different retention requirements so it
usually leads to programs where you have
to look at an organizational view of the
world and profile who has data how much
data they have where is that data
located what are their retention
policies what is their security policies
what are their schemas quite frankly
this usually leads to large-scale
efforts that take multiple years to try
and create a data map across an
organization again might be a worthwhile
effort and it's something that people
have to do to make the kind of the world
a better place organizationally but it's
distracting from what most people want
to do which is just actually use data
and drive value from their data a common
solution to this problem is the drive to
data warehouses and I'll preface this
was saying data lakes and data
warehouses coexist so this is don't
don't interpret this slide saying data
lakes and data warehouses are
diametrically opposed they actually
coexist and there's really good reasons
why you actually want both but a common
knee-jerk reaction to kind of the data
messiness that's driven by all this
organizational complexity is
centralization and a very common form of
central centralization is creating a
large-scale data warehouse and then you
take all of these efforts and then you
design schemas that are cross-functional
and you have committees that try and
figure out
what scheme is you need and how you
break everything apart you may drive
value from the data warehouse but that
also introduces its own complexities in
terms of costs in terms of getting
everybody to agree on what schemas you
want in terms of access so just driving
to a data warehouse is an end result
make sense in some cases but not all
cases so data lakes can simplify and
optimize for these problems very simply
a data can break down organizational
walls so it seems very simple because it
is actually a pretty simple concept
instead of focusing on different data
technologies because you have these
organizational silos and you have people
thinking kind of in a box with a common
store with a common data Lake if you put
data in that data Lake it's much easier
to think about it's much easier for
teams to see what other teams have it's
much easier to store that data it's much
easier to think about security much
easier to think about retention all
because instead of trying to silo data
and partition it across different
technologies different processing tools
you're putting it in one data Lake I
mentioned that data lakes and data
warehouses are complementary and that is
very true so we'll talk about the how
data lakes and data warehouses are
complementary inside of GCP but they
both have their purpose a data Lake is a
great single shared common resource it's
a great place to store data of all types
it's really a in many cases jack of all
trades master of none
data Lakes can be read from from many
applications data Lakes have a great
utility in storing data until you know
what you want to do with it or until you
load it into a subset of data and often
put it into an application or a specific
purpose now data warehouses are really
good at what they do there are very good
reasons why you would want to take a
subset of data and apply schemas to it
and have sub second or very low latency
query ability on that data ensure that
the data is clean is formatted as
consistent that data warehouses are very
very good at that data warehouses are
not very good at just storing lots and
lots of data because you go through the
process of loading that data normal
that day and then flying ski mister that
data likewise data lakes are not great
at offering sub second queries even with
tools like however in some cases presto
you may get to lower latency queries but
they're not going to generally match the
semantics of data warehouses so both of
these tools are very complementary in a
data-driven organization I want to talk
through how you would build a data Lake
on GCP if you were to get started today
and this is coming from the assumption
that you just don't have kind of any
data in GCP at all
I mentioned hallmark of data lakes is
that you have the single store of data
and in Google cloud platform cloud
storage is the hub or the central spoke
of a data Lake there's a lot of
semantics tied to cloud storage that
make it the central hub or spoke for
your data Lake first you can use it
across many many products cloud storage
is well connected and well integrated to
many cloud platform products you can
optimize your cost and availability
based on different availability tiers
different storage tiers inside of cloud
storage
I did in fact to count the number of
nines because I was curious and there's
nine nines after the decimal there's a
very high durability in cloud storage
you don't need to think about how you're
going to necessarily backup your data or
what happens it's incredibly durable you
can also apply centralized management
and security policies so within if
you've not used cloud storage before you
can apply policies on buckets you can
apply policies on objects you have a lot
of flexibility to specify what happens
to items and inside of a day like that's
nice because you can do that in a
central place instead of having to
figure out whichever a number of
technologies you're using to to try and
figure out then how to apply policies to
them something that some people know
about that's not obvious but one of the
most interesting features for cloud
storage is immediate consistency and
I'll talk about this as it pertains to
the SPARC and Hadoop ecosystem which I
know quite well but immediate
consistency is actually really really
important to the data Lake best way to
summarize media consistency is when you
put something in the data Lake
in this case cloud storage it's
immediately available through a list
operation and cloud storage this is
really important because if you have
multiple producers and consumers that
are pointing at the same bucket if
somebody puts a file there and you want
to immediately process that file you
want that file to be immediately
available in a list operation otherwise
somebody may miss it or worse if one
person gets it in a list operation
another person does not get into list
operation all of a sudden you have
discontinuity between two different
users of your data so the fact that
cloud storage has immediate list
consistency is actually really really
important in terms of thinking about a
data Lake the different storage classes
in cloud storage are very very important
semantics for building a data Lake on
GCP there's a couple of really important
points to take care first there's a
single consistent storage API and
availability across all of these storage
shares so instead of having to try and
reason and think about do I use regional
buckets or cold line and how long does
it take to get something out of cold
line or what different api's do I need
to use to access cold line versus near
line you don't have to think about
different api's you don't have to think
about latency for getting things out of
cold lines you don't need to introduce
you know seconds minutes hours for
getting data between these availability
tiers the availability tiers also will
allow you to pick and choose sometimes
there are very valid reasons why you
want things available very very quickly
there are a lot of times you may want
something available or excuse me you may
want something that costs less but
you're going to access less frequently
so in a lot of cases people will take
archive data that they don't expect to
use and they'll put it in cold line you
can also apply policies on buckets and
on objects and that's actually really
important so in this case say you have a
bunch of things and you keep them in a
regional bucket and then after 30 days
you want to put them in your line you
keep them in your line for 30 days and
then you put them in cold mine for a
year this is really important because
this is actually very sim
to how a lot of organizations think
about and use data there's generally
only a subset of data which they're
using with any regularity it's very
uncommon for people to use all of their
data all the time it's very common with
people to access or work on their most
recent data most frequently and they
still want access to their older data
but they don't necessarily need access
all the time or access is very very
infrequent there's a lot of reasons for
that you know the data that people
produce changes over time the
trustworthiness or accuracy of the data
may change over time doesn't mean you
want to get rid of the data it just
means that you don't necessarily need
access to it all the time data leaks fit
into a flow it's thinking about data so
when you ingest data it's very very
common to ingest data into that day
awake and then try and figure out or
maybe already know but that data Lake is
is there until you take action on that
data in some way or some form so for
example you may ship all of your logs
all of your blob data you may have
images store all of that in your data
link in some cases people already know
what they want to do with that data and
they just take a subset of that data and
process it and put it in maybe a
transactional database or some
front-of-house system in other cases
people may want to keep data in that
data Lake until they know what to do and
that's the power of a daily it gives you
that flexibility to keep the data at
rest you may immediately act on a subset
of it and put it in a particular place
and you only have to act on a subset of
it you don't have to keep the whole data
chunk in one piece putting it in a more
specialized system or you can just keep
the data there until you know what you
want to do with it there's multiple
places where you may want to think about
loading and reading data inside of
Google cloud platform there's a lot of
text on this slide thankfully a lot of
people are taking pictures of the slide
all of this is also documented online in
a guide that I will post a link to at
the very end here but the key point I
want to make here is GCS as the center
of your data lake is great for just
during large amounts of data there are
other storage products that you can use
for more specific needs so application
based needs you may want data inside of
an enterprise data warehouse and you
loaded into bigquery you may want to put
data inside of cloud spanner but most
likely you're not going to want to put
all of your data in Claude's manner
you're not want all of your data is not
appropriate for BigTable so with cloud
storage you can keep all of your data in
a centralized data Lake and then use
each technology appropriately for a very
specific purpose there's multiple ways
that you can fill thaad storage so
hypothetically say you have a lot of
data that's just existing somewhere in
the known universe
there's batch ways you can load that
data so you can use gsutil which ships
as part of the Google Cloud SDK there's
a storage transfer service you can use
something like disk CP if you're using
the SPARC and Hadoop ecosystem it's
actually that's very very common for
people that are moving data from HDFS to
cloud storage you can stream the data
using something like pub/sub and cloud
dataflow there's also a transfer
appliance there's also a number of
partners who can help you move data to
cloud storage in both a one-time and
replicated way depending on whichever
needs you have I want to provide some
conceptual examples before I invite
Zulily to stage to provide a very
practical example of how data Lake on
GCP is useful and how that works kind of
in theory and in practice really good
example is replacing HDFS and a spark in
Hadoop cluster very common for people to
have sparking to do clusters to store
data and for them to scale that cluster
out because they need to store more data
in HDFS as an example of how cloud
storage can be a really good data Lake
in GCP there's a Hadoop compatible file
system connector there's a connector
that implant implements the Hadoop
compatible file system API available for
cloud data proc
to and from cloud storage via SPARC and
Hadoop and you don't have to think about
HDFS anymore that also freezing from
having to think about replication it
frees you from having to think about
scale of
it also generally is incredibly
performant so you'll actually often see
much better performance from cloud
storage with cloud data proc than
reading and writing even to something
like persistent disk doesn't necessarily
mean that you would want to use cloud
storage for everything in the Sun in
some cases temporary i/o may be more
appropriate on local SSD it may mean
that you want to paralyze your workloads
and avoid doing things like massive
renames but in general the nice thing
about having cloud storage data Lake is
you're no longer thinking about the
biggest pain which is the underlying
file system and how you actually manage
that file system to store your data I
mentioned consistency this is a good
example of why consistency is important
if you have multiple SPARC and Hadoop
clusters that are reading and writing
from one bucket at the same time they
all need to be in sync in terms of what
they see in that bucket
if they're out of sync you're going to
get different results so you're just
dropping a new file in every second and
all you're doing in a spark drop is
counting the number of files something
that's simple if you don't have
immediate consistency you're going to
get different results very very quickly
so consistency is a really really big
deal for daily and it's also a really
good example of why Cloud Storage is
they're very very good data Lee
mentioned segmenting data by classes so
people generally don't access all of
their data at once it's usually a very
very small portion of their data which
means that in a traditional world in
this case HDFS they're paying one cost
for all of their data even though
they're only accessing a small portion
of their data frequently with different
storage classes you can keep that
frequently accessed data in something
like a regional bucket and then start
segmenting your data to different
classes depending on how frequently you
think or you just know you you need to
access that data you also have a choice
of processing tools with cloud storage
so in this case if you have data and
cloud storage you can read that data
from cloud data proc you can read it
from data flow you can do federated
queries on that data from bigquery you
can analyze that data with cloud data
prep in this example say you analyze the
data and plot data prep and then you
load a subset of that day
into bigquery very good example of a
data Lake in action
very likely all of the data that you
would analyze with something like data
prep you're not going to just dump into
bigquery because say you remove you know
15% of data because it's just not what
you need to keep in bigquery in all
likelihood you don't want to immediately
just destroy that data which gives you a
very nice separation between the
appropriateness of bigquery is an
enterprise data warehouse and cloud
storage is a data link you also have the
flexibility of file formats and cloud
storage and in general with with data
leaks so in this case say you have data
that's parquet and Avro and org you
don't have to think about different
storage mediums for each type of these
file formats within even the same folder
you can have files of all these file
formats coexist as long as the consumer
knows what to expect or can introspect
the files and deal with them
appropriately you're good to go you
don't have to configure your data Lake
and manage based on the file format
there's a lot of boxes on this slide the
important takeaway is cloud storage can
be the central spoke of your data
platform as a data Lake on GCP so for
example you could read data in batch
from data flow or data proc you can
stream data from pub/sub from data flow
you can refine that data put it in
something like spanner bigquery but at
the hub all of your just data either
that's been processed or raw data is
inside of cloud storage has your data
leak with that I want to invite our
friends from Zulily to stage to walk
through a practical example of how they
built a data leak on GCP years ago and
specifically talk about what Google
Cloud Storage meant for us and dead for
us among the other data products that
Google has to offer so this presentation
is really talking about analytics and
machine learning and how cloud storage
can actually be a repository for doing
all of that
a little bit about myself I am director
of machine learning data science
Angelelli
you know it's a it's a loosely defined
role machine learning data science can
mean very different things at different
organizations but at Zulily what this
means is I work with multiple teams of
data scientists machine learning
engineers and data engineers to drive
experiences that engage our customers
whether they're our external customers
or internal customers within the retail
enterprise
so what Zulily Zulily
is growing and thriving in its own
category of e-commerce and that's making
shopping entertaining and fun we present
a third way to shop which is discovery
based shopping unlike brick-and-mortar
retailers and traditional online
retailers which are intent-based
directed search driven so Lili is more
about a browse and discover experience
so I said commoditized search you know
if you want CAD food you go search for
cat food you find a bunch of options
you've like you know pick the one you
like most relevant to your needs and you
go buy something so Lilly is not that
you think about Zulily as a newspaper or
a magazine there is a new addition every
day right and the goal is we want to
drive engagement we want our customers
to be curious about what we have on the
site today and come back to see what's
new and fresh so how do we do that
we launched over 9,000 products every
single day through hundred plus sales
events on our website we work with
around 15,000 brands to make this happen
so it's a it's an interesting business
model but what it requires is the
agility and the nimbleness across the
board because we are really revamping
relaunching that same site over and over
again
every single day and what it also means
is we have to make data accessible to
all of our partners within the
organization whether they're mulch
indices were working with the external
vendors to get their products on -
there's a lily platform or they are
marketing specialists who are trying to
figure out what kind of ad campaigns to
launch the same day in the next day of
next week
data is key we also have three
fulfillment centers in the United States
and so we want all of our associates in
the fulfillment center to have access to
data near real-time and really drive
their decision-making using that data so
that was really the goal and how we are
as an organization so where is Lily
today by the way we launched in 2010 so
we are a relatively young company eight
year old but right now 70% of our orders
are actually placed through mobile
devices and 91% of our orders are
actually coming through repeat customers
and that is the key and that is really
the focus of this talk didn't happen
overnight
you know it's a process that we went
through so what was a journey where we
ended up here and how did Google help in
that journey to make this happen
we lost the presentation on that side
okay
so four years ago the business was
growing our product categories were
expanding the customer base was growing
significantly and that's the time where
the company you know we recognized that
the structure we had in place did not
meet the needs for our future growth
potential right that's where we started
looking at what our options we started
looking into big data but the core of
thread we really wanted to bear make our
own Big Data Platform right we we are we
are a tech you know company at heart we
have a biased world a very strong bias
to build and from that perspective we
went back to the drawing board and said
hey we want to build this big data
platform to democratize data to all of
our partners internally and also improve
our customer experience to those who are
coming to our site every day so there
were key key components there back in
the day we had silos of data
unstructured data coming through
clickstream you know who's clicking on
what page what products are they viewing
which one they are it called one what
did the purchase right so all of that
data is coming it's it's all
unstructured on the other hand we had
transactional data stores right every
application whether it's you know the
products customers are buying to you
know our marketing campaigns all of that
data lived in traditional sequel like
data stores so wanted to get everything
together correlating something from you
know a user interaction and unstructured
data in the click stream to something on
our transactional DB was a hard thing at
the time so it was clear to us we had to
get the data together in a single place
and then figure out a mechanism to make
it available to everyone and in a timely
fashion
scalability was important reliability
durability flexibility you know our
business is really flexible so we wanted
to have Factory and all the flexibility
up front before we proceeded with
anything
we had workloads with varying
requirements some of them would be batch
processes that we would run you know
once a day
some were every three minutes but they
were also a desire to get the data in
near real-time so there was definitely a
real-time component of that and we
wanted part of all of that data which in
the first place we didn't know what data
we needed and how we would use that data
right and that's where the data Lake
came in the centralized data storage can
we just put all of the data pockets on
there and over time we'll figure out
what's the best use of that data and as
we determine what that user scenario the
key scenario is that we are trying to
target that's when we will do all of the
transformations and magic will happen on
this data and we will make it available
in our big data warehouse which will be
available to the rest of the
organization and they will run their
business from this big data warehouse
data access and visualization is key we
do a lot of reporting like I mentioned
you know our fulfillment centers need to
know what's the status of all no orders
house shipping happening or marketers
need to know what what how they're our
campaigns are performing over the course
of the day do we need to you know
course-correct something based on the
data we are seeing so there was a strong
desire to get data as soon as possible
and also be able to visualize it for
easier consumption and the core data
services which were really making that
data available to everyone whether it's
a non non tech partner in different
parts of the organization or it is for
consumption within the technology
organization itself so our journey was
more around the centralized big data
storage we evaluated Google Cloud
Storage we really liked that it
supported all of our needs from you know
structure to the unstructured data and
like I said at the time we were not even
clear you know we had a few core
scenarios we wanted to address but we
wanted to future-proof ourselves so it
really fed the needs for a big data
warehouse we actually use bigquery and
again there we have over a hundred plus
disparate data sources that we're
actually pulling the data from at
different time intervals some of them
are near real time some of them you know
running every hour or every day cadence
so we've had to build some tooling
around that we built some capability
internally that would actually
synchronize the data from the disparate
data sources whether it's a sequel data
store new no sequel data store or or
just gathering all of the real-time
clickstream and make it available in the
centralized data storage that GCS Google
Cloud Storage and then we actually used
a lot of static clusters in the
beginning and then moved on to Google
data proc to actually solve for some of
the core scenarios that were critical
for the rest of the organization so what
are the key data sets that we want to
make available to the rest of the
company that they can actually drive
their day-to-day business from so we use
POC and Hadoop to do all of the batch
processing in some cases we use spark
streaming for real-time processing and
we made that data available in bigquery
and bigquery was great because the
barrier to entry is low it's not just
limited to the data scientists and
analysts it's a very easy sequel like
interface that I think half of our
company actually or more than half the
company actually uses it it's
interesting because our PR team just
told me here I went into bigquery the
other day and I got this data so that
was pretty cool to see how people
outside of technology are embracing it
and being able to leverage to run their
decision-making to run the business
so that's really what I was talking
about which is we wanted to make the
data available as a self-service
capability to the rest of the business
bigquery is what we use but really it
was the data from Google Cloud storage
and manipulating transforming that data
joining multiple data sets together to
actually make something meaningful and
compelling for our business stakeholders
to consume that is what is available in
bigquery and they can do all of the
reporting dashboard on top of that they
can actually get any intraday statistics
that they need to answer some of the
business questions the other thing which
was really interesting and was enough
you know an outcome of this we have a
lot of inbuilt
tools and applications I mentioned we
have a huge merchandising organization
that's that's getting all of our vendors
onboard the platform right what we want
to do is over the course of the day as
the products are launched on the site
can we provide some insights to our
merchandisers and our external vendors
on one how their products are actually
performing on the site you know how many
demand are they generating what this
conversion looked like and and really
give them the data and the insight they
need to take action and so we built some
applications around that where this is
an example of a merchandising dashboard
it's an application which is used by
over 500 people within the company but
really this is driving them to look at
the data and consume the data in an easy
fashion and then have something that's
actionable as a result of looking at
this data and the visualization itself
so once we rolled this application out
we really saw there was you know high
engagement in our organization and they
really started to pick up on big data
and the Google platform itself
the other thing I want to stress on is
we we have a dynamic business model or
our catalog is changing every day we
want to get people to come back to our
site every day so we do that with
personalization right it's a it's a
one-to-one hyper personalized experience
for every customer so in that sense we
are actually serving millions of
versions of our site every day and we do
it with the power of the data that we
are gathering from all of the disparate
data sources trying to understand you
know what do our customers like what are
their preferences and and we really hear
from them and learn from them and then
take those learnings to drive their
future experiences so in this case I
have the same day same time there are
three different customers who came to
this a lily site on your left
extreme left is a customer who buys
apparel and fitness gear and the middle
was a shopper who came through Footwear
advertisement and landed on on our site
and on the extreme right is a customer
who predominantly buys for her kids and
home goods so you can see the the
experience is radically different for
all of our customers and this is key to
driving engagement right this goes back
to by doing all of that we were able to
get to 91% of our orders today are
actually coming from repeat customers we
have over 6.1 million active customers
today our number of active customers has
grown 25 24 percent year-over-year or
revenues at the end of q1 had drawn 17
percent year-over-year currently we are
at 1.6 billion dollars and one of the
things I want to mention I mentioned
this in the context of the data platform
itself is the data lives in Google Cloud
storage right
we are gathering all of the data but
even to power the machine learning and
personalization experience we are
actually leveraging the the Hadoop spark
ecosystem the data proc clusters that
Google has to offer and using that we
are creating all the features that we
need to drive the personalization
experience and again depending on what
kind of features we are building what
kind of transformations the cadence will
vary some are near real-time some are
you know every half hour every day and
so forth
one of the other interesting challenges
here is people who work you know
familiar with the machine learning
personalization recommendation systems
play space is there is an inherent rip
you know presentation bias and in
machine learning joggin and what does
that mean that means is if a customer
never sees a product they're never going
to click on it if they never click into
it they're never going to buy it right
so one of the places where we use Google
Cloud Storage was also to address that
problem of presentation-wise how do we
bring transparency into what we do and
how we do and share it with our business
partners so they understand what is the
exposure that personalization is driving
through the customer base and we did
that by having all of our logs so when
we are serving by the way these are
served in near-real-time right so as we
are solving these experiences to
customers based on their latest and
greatest data we are actually logging
those experiences and we make those logs
available in GCS which helps us to
actually mind those logs after the fact
or him during the course of the day at
periodic intervals and be able to
present reports and dashboards to all
four partners telling them how
personalization is actually driving
exposure from our customers on the
products that they care about which was
very insightful as well
so I mentioned briefly how it works you
know we're launching millions of sites
every day we receive all of that data we
process that data this is where Google
Cloud Storage comes into the picture we
are using data Pro cluster to train our
machine learning models based on the
features that we are deriving from that
data and we're using that to inform the
future experiences for our customers
it drives higher revenue engagement but
above all it makes our customers happy
so there are other places where we are
actually using or my partners and on the
marketing side are actually using that
data to actually figure out what the
customer lifetime value is and and they
do that by really looking at that data
again and seeing okay who are our
existing high-value customers what were
the behaviors that actually separate
these from the rest and as we are trying
to acquire new customers can we actually
find who those high-value customers are
based on the behaviors that they are
exhibiting so again it unlocks unleashes
a lot of power a lot of capability that
you can build on top so it's been a
great journey you know I talked about
all of the positives I do want to talk
about you know what are some of the key
challenges as well one of the things
that James mentioned I want to echo
which was a positive and and I missed it
was the strong consistency we are
actually gathering this data at scale
it's really high volume we're looking at
billions of key data points over the
course of the day so we want to make
sure as one process is writing the data
while the other process is reading that
data it has the latest and greatest data
right so the immediate consistency in
Google Cloud Storage is critical to
enable that so what are the challenges
or what are things that you know would
be great to have I mentioned at the
beginning of my talk that this is more
round repository for
lyrics and machine learning if it's a
repository it has to have some mechanism
of making that data discoverable
currently that is one of the challenges
we deal with where the different teams
generating different data sets how do we
make sure that we are able to reuse some
of the capability a different team has
already produced right how do we enable
that ease of discovery in the Google
Cloud Storage one of the things I've
loved you know working with the Google
team is the the collaboration that we
you know work together to identify such
problems and make improvements in the
products so that is a conversation we
are having I don't want to steal any
thunder from them but this is something
that's critical to me personally and and
I recognize that it is for other
partners other companies as well
the other is regulations right so we are
living in a world where regulations are
evolving their compliance so how do we
ensure that all of these data sets that
we've accrued over time is how easy is
it to incorporate a new regulation new
compliance or legal clause right that's
one of the challenges where we had to
rethink you know again we are a
relatively young company just been there
eight years we never had to deal with
you know decades-old data but that's
something that we've started thinking
about now is what is that data retention
policy and how does that play into
Google Cloud Storage so for people who
are actually onboarding Google now I
think that would be one of the things
you should just bake in and think about
now versus later data annotation
duplication sort of ties in to data
discovery but this is again more around
duplication or we repeating the work and
we actually take advantage of the work
that somebody else has done to generate
a data set and use that instead so those
are the things that I think are really
top of mind for me and
I would love to solve and I would love
to solve it in collaboration with Google
so I I will pass on the mic to James and
we will be open to questions in a bit
thank you very much all right so before
we leave and take questions and we have
a few minutes for questions here I
wanted to leave you with a few resources
that you could look at the you could get
involved with for more information if
this was interesting if this topic is
near and dear to you we wanted to point
you in the right direction so there is a
talk it is happening it's actually after
this talk it's an i/o talk on moving
data to the cloud it's going to cover
much more specifically how you actually
do something like move large sets of
data to cloud storage if that topic is
interesting to you please do check it
out there's also a lot of documentation
on the cloud Google comm site for
building a data Lake thinking about the
life cycle of data on Google cloud
platform and using data in cloud storage
as a data lake with our big data tools
you also find that a lot of the products
like data proc or data flow bigquery
actually have their own documentation as
well for working with cloud storage for
usually more specific use cases whether
it be something like spark streaming or
streaming and Apache beam or doing a
federated query in bigquery so if you
are curious on how to use cloud storage
as the data lake with product X Y or Z I
would actually recommend look at the
documentation for that product and
usually you will find
[Music]
you